CAT ALLMAN: Hi, this is Cat
Allman with Google's Open
Source Programs Office.
I'm here today with my
colleague, Carol Smith.
Carol manages our Google
Summer of Code program.
And we're here
today for the second
of our interviews
about that program.
Specifically, we're
here today to talk
about applying as a
mentoring organization.
So Carol, what the heck is a
mentoring organization anyway?
CAROL SMITH: So mentoring
organizations, at a minimum,
are organizations which
have already released code
under an OSI-approved
license and have
at least two contributors
in their community who
would like to participate in
the program as mentors and org
admins.
CAT ALLMAN: And can a school
be a mentoring organization?
CAROL SMITH: They can.
We've had universities
participate in the past,
again, assuming that
they've released code
under an OSI-approved
license and they
have at least two contributors
would like to participate.
But they should keep
in mind that if they
have any requirements
from their university,
in terms of their time,
that they should make sure
that they can balance
those two things.
CAT ALLMAN: And can a company
be a mentoring organization?
CAROL SMITH: They can.
We're a little bit more
restrictive about which
companies we accept.
Again, they have to meet the
requirements of having already
released code under an
OSI-approved license, which
may or may not be the
case for some companies.
But yes, they're still
welcome to apply.
CAT ALLMAN: Great.
Why would an organization or a
free and open source software
project want to participate?
CAROL SMITH: For
a couple reasons.
One is because
they might get code
that they might
not have otherwise
been able to create from
the student developers who
participate in the program.
And also, we've heard
from organizations
that they get recognized
on a wider, broader
international open source stage.
CAT ALLMAN: All right.
How much of a time
commitment is it?
CAROL SMITH: For
mentors, it tends
to be about five hours a week.
But it will really depend on
how the organization's code
base is, what sorts of projects
they have the students working
on, and how they treat
and work with developers.
So we just try to give that
as a general guideline.
CAT ALLMAN: And what
about the org admin role?
What's involved in being the
org admin for the project?
CAROL SMITH: Quite a few things.
One is submitting
the application
to participate in the
program, but also they
need to be able to manage the
entire scope of participating
in Google Summer of Code.
So making sure that the
mentors are submitting
their evaluations on
time during the program,
making sure that the
students are on track,
making sure the projects
are all on track.
And also submitting all the
forms and all the things
that are required
by Google as well.
CAT ALLMAN: Related
to that, Google
uses the Melange
software that we've
developed to run the program.
Is that optional, or do projects
have to work with Melange?
CAROL SMITH: They
have to use Melange,
and anything that they
do outside of Melange
isn't recognized by Google
as part of the program.
And so they're still
welcome to do that,
but they need to duplicate
that effort within our project.
CAT ALLMAN: Great.
All-important question, when
is the application period?
CAROL SMITH: So applications are
open right now, which is great.
And the application deadline
is next week, on Friday,
February 14, at 1900
UTC, which if you're
on the West Coast of
the US, is 11:00 AM.
CAT ALLMAN: Great.
What about the application
itself, are there any gotchas,
or where can they get help?
CAROL SMITH: So if they would
like to just get some general
guidelines on how to
submit their application,
I would direct them
into our website,
which is google-melange.com.
And on that site we have
a pretty extensive FAQ,
which has information
about their ideas pages
and also about participating
as a mentoring organization
generally.
And then within the FAQ, we also
have linked a mentor and org
admin manual, which is actually
written by mentors and org
admins who have
participated in the past
and intended for exactly these
kinds of people who would like
to participate in the program.
If they still have questions
that they haven't gotten
answered, or they'd like
help with our application,
we also have a general
discussion mailing list
that they can ask their
specific question on.
CAT ALLMAN: Great.
Is there a single,
most common mistake
that orgs should look out for?
CAROL SMITH: Yeah, one of
the most common mistakes
is not spending enough
time on your ideas page.
As part of the application to
be a mentoring organization,
we ask all the
applicants to submit
what's called an "ideas page."
Which is essentially just
a list of the projects
that they think
students might like
to work on during
the summer time.
But we want them to make
sure that they've really
thought about what that
project is going to look like,
how much of a time
commitment it's going to be,
whether they have the potential
mentors to mentor that project,
and really what the
difficulty level is.
So if anything, I would
recommend that organizations
spend most of their
time on making
sure their ideas page
is really high quality.
CAT ALLMAN: Great.
If an org has applied and
been rejected in the past,
is it a waste of time
for them to apply again?
CAROL SMITH: Absolutely not.
Having been rejected in
the past has no bearing
on what decisions we make in
any given year of applications.
But if they've gotten
feedback on what
was wrong with our application
or why they were rejected
in the past, I'd recommend
that they definitely
integrate that and change
those things for this year's
application.
CAT ALLMAN: Great.
Have I forgotten
to ask you anything
that you get asked a lot online?
CAROL SMITH: No,
but we always have
lots of students who are
interested in volunteering
for open source projects.
So if they are even thinking
about applying for GSoC,
they can definitely
start talking
to students and
potential applicants
now, if they'd like to.
CAT ALLMAN: Fantastic.
Well, thank you
very much, Carol.
And thank you all
for joining us.
If you have an open
source project,
and you're considering applying,
we certainly hope you do.
And happy GSoc.